everything in life comes down to what
your own value system is if you just
gave me a sheet that told me what those
were about somebody I would tell you
what the outcome of their life is going
to be because implementation is really a
question of skill set so it that's why
motivation ultimately is going to let
you down it's like you're motivated to
try this thing which you don't know how
to do and you suck at it and so you go
do that thing you suck it hurts your ego
psychological immune system kicks in
reminds them that that was stupid anyway
why were they worried about even trying
that and so they back off what do you
have to do to counteract that and the
thing you have to do is emotionally
reward yourself for being willing to
take the steps stop valuing myself for
being good at something and start
valuing myself for being willing to
learn so I hit the the wall of my
inadequacy and I don't meet that with
stopping I meet that with cool now I
know what I have to get better at then I
just put the work into developing the
skill people think that like if it's
real If It's Love then there's no energy
that's put into building that up and I
think that's BS